[Music]
try not to overextend your
elbows
[Music]
for
for for
[Music]
okay still just a little bit of desire
to do it so like here's where you have
it okay you push past it now now you're
exposed okay
so careful try to bring him more into
your movement then you can stay in
midrange
gra
okay so careful like you you have you
feel like you have them okay now you
start pushing your overextending then
your arms get
St so if you if you have them here then
take them this
way you keep your
arms more
Compact and next if you end up on your
elbow careful you're that much closer to
close range grab if he passes
it let know like we're not playing the
game anymore like you want to come in
for a body lock you see on
it so if you find yourself and you're
here okay find a way to get
back okay to get it happens so as you
just realize that you're moving in here
yeah you have the connection but I'd
rather that you come back to the P okay
so two things we're working on is don't
straighten your arms and then the second
thing if you get on the edge of
mid-range
grappling understand that that happened
it's not it's very easy to go back to
the other Eng of mid-range gra okay
you're on the border with close
range okay
good so you didn't hyper extend you
called it back
yet
good good
careful take use the circle more so
you're not
overextending better
pull them in
yes good always want one hand Yin that's
how you make the circle not too young
yes there you go now you're not
overextending pull them in
he
[Music]
good
for for
bring him into kazushi for
earlier then then he'll respond to it
then you might have to change direction
don't don't play arm patty cake you
touch kazushi he has to do
something you guys understand that all
right
I'm not in this range right not close
enough to touch right okay so I got to
be close I got to be close enough to
touch so I'm like this range but I
should never be
here I need to be at the 45 p.m or the
pm. so there we are and we can still
touch the forearm the hand to the Elbow
r is this range is mid-range grav okay
now I'm always here
but we're here on a
rotation get there's an energy that's
doing this this walk you understand
we're not it's not that we're doing this
he be he's coming in at me do you see
you get it there's a rotation so there's
a centrifugal and a cental energy
because of how where I move so I'm not
in other words as I throws the strike
I'm not going to go to the 45 and not
there's no rotation you see that I have
to move to the 45 to keep this thing
going so this time in order to keep it
going I had to go to the other 45 to
keep it going okay you guys understand
so that force is happening to us now
let's it's hard to talk
and and work with the actual centrifugal
energy and the cental energy
okay um so for but if we just walk
around just walk around normal you're
not you're not a Victor like you're
trying to grab me do you understand
you're trying to grab me okay if I just
keep his spine straight you could do any
number of things not
everything if I was in front of him he
could do everything at the angle he
could do more things if we're not moving
but when we're
moving he can do less things but still
quite a bit okay he can duck under he
can pull he can go around and a lot to
account for so that is why I don't just
stick and follow I always
tilt you have to tilt took away a lot of
things
okay so he's trying to hit your
chest and you don't want to just stick
you don't want to just hold he's not
much tilt you have to touch and tilt you
see then he has to do something to get
off of it and that's what opens up other
stuff
or you're just in you see got enough
tilt where you're going to dis
project but you should you have to
occupy with the Tilt every time he has
to get off of the
Tilt so not like this I know you can do
this but it's not what we do okay touch
tilt touch
tilt tilt
ta so here's his thrust you
see and that's what I tilt the other
hand will help
you use the two
hands combinations of he's pushing you
see and I C you into a
tilt I here into do the
Tilt see okay but I have to tilt you can
me pushes right you can yield you see i
y I got out of the way and then you can
pick
[Music]
up home you then you can pick it up kind
do any of this stuff okay but he has to
tell you're not going to sit
here and do this
okay um also
remember mid-range grappling like I said
just now it's
here okay so this is The Edge just like
I don't want to use my elbow cuz I'm at
the edge of close range grappling the
border between the to same thing you get
on his elbows you're you're at that edge
okay so he gets on he gets on my elbows
and we're in
okay so resist like uh you're comeing
here and you'll see that elbow right
maybe you go here just simply roll out
you'll still have
it so I'm here yeah I'm pushing I'm
extending and at his elbow I roll out
and take the hand now this way and come
back towards the hand okay so earlier we
said try to not use your elbows and now
I'm asking you to stay away from his
elbows okay how do you do that you just
come back this way okay come back this
way you'll find pretty much any adhesion
point that you have here where you're
doing this stuff you come here and
you'll have it right back
okay all right
[Music]
get him in the Tilt he's to he's upright
too
long it's cuz you're pushing back on him
better
better tilt right away tilt he tilts as
soon as you touch you
tilt no see he's upright
[Music]
watch the long arms we're
advancing tilt tilt oh sorry
[Music]
good good
try not to
grab get some yielding you have two
youngs
yep try to get away from those
elbows it comes from it actually comes
from overextending from pushing and
they're trying to get off you're going
to slip up you're going to slip up the
arm okay so if you would stop pushing at
her it wouldn't happen Okay but if it
does cuz they might counter you then you
you have that other skill but if we sto
pushing we wouldn't be in
that find her Center get out of her
shoulders
feel when her mind goes on one arm don't
let it pull your mind to that arm you
put pay attention to the other arm
right someone's going to get you sooner
or later you're trying to Wing CH this
person do you understand so what we
doing is right at first pressure go
ahead right at first pressure I'm in
that tilt I have the same seizure but
I'm working a particular
tactic okay this is trapping skills you
see trapping and passing skills you get
it so she in other words she pushes on a
hand and then I yield you see and then
you have this this kind of stuff it's
very low
percentage what you can do is the same
she you do that same push I could do the
same tracking skill and get the angle
okay you understand so it's not enough
to just here and stay in here and just
pass and stuff sees right and then
tilts and
then okay
sees he does whatever that's my yielding
[Music]
angle okay
not too
Youngs find her Center through there
you're slipping on her arm and that's
how you're getting up to the Elbow touch
find the center through each
hand okay so what's happening she has
two to many angle variables when she's
upright do do you get there is too many
angle variables it's the same thing
you're on the line you see we're going
to fight what am I going to
do I'm going to attack
you what do you think I'm going to do
stra okay
really you there's too many angles for
you to be able to tell we reduce those
angles by adding tension you start
circling the F you see that no that
angle's gone that angle's gone you see
you get it okay and you by circling I
now become reaction you stay here I'm
active you start circling I got to
enough turn you see so I lose initiative
you start cutting away some of my
potential angles of attack it's easier
to now defend yourself okay the
more I am away from one of the kazushi
patterns and you are away from one of
the shikaku
angles it's just a matter of time I'm
going to get you okay so that is
why when you're here like this she she
can do she has single angle and
combination so if you Pi she can make
every one of those 360s coming around
see okay she can go this way too and
this way she can do the diagonals you
see and you're like trying to stay up
with that it's like it's just a matter
of time okay so again the order is not
to be here
external in the center okay got it now
she has to respond cuz though here I am
if you push into me you see H balis is
now on her back foot you see just when
she thrust she can let me
say she can feel that so if she pushes
it then you have her already so she's
going to get off of it get off of that
seizure you have right there you see you
get it it was like oh where am I
going now I don't have any seir you see
and now she can move her hands any other
way and I'm trying to stay up with this
thing
so hard to do she look how much angles
that I have to
cover okay oh she would had that one
right
there
okay but what you do instead the order
of operation is I touch
sees okay wear's her y energy
deviate right and start to tilt she'll
respond but she can't respond every old
way you see so let's go back here we're
around this tilt and try to come around
the outside of this arm BR is bringing
her more into it so she would feel that
and any athlete would feel that that's
that's why she came around to the other
arm she's trying to flee the other arm
that's getting her but you keep now able
to keep using those little tiny angles I
don't know if the camera can see
it okay so here's the here's the seizure
right so let's say there's your Center
but I don't keep it in the Tilt she can
RIS roll around and she's free you see
but if I keep pulling and her little rib
this roll doesn't do anything okay so
you canceling out angles you guys
understand so right at touch you're
already moving there's little micro
she's trying you just I'm just micro
adjusting to
it see it looks to you like I am just
touching her and going but I'm not she's
she's constantly micro adjusting and I'm
micro adjusting at the seizure Point
okay I don't have to move my hand to
adjust at the seizure point so if we if
we go slow and you agree to stay
slow she's getting
off okay got it
so touch seize tilt okay now you now
you're taking away a lot of possible
angles it's a little easier
okay come off the elbows better good
that's
it
tilt there you
go you have like a second when you
remember the other hand like you're like
oh yeah then you start the Tilt okay try
to get it more fluid without that Gap
here we go
better it's his it's his job to un get
unseized
good stay grounded or you'll get
projected off yourself when you project
[Music]
then
what what's that Virginia honey
[Music]
so again we're getting there that was
like everyone's doing very well remember
where we started okay remember where we
started so we're now not allowing you up
here
okay
um I'm not allowing you here okay if it
happens it happens but in training try
to understand where this stuff happens
okay this is this this range is you're
losing it okay all
right and we have some grounding we
still have some pushing
okay but the fact that you're able to
push somewhere able to ground is the
drill
has a overlap between correct form like
two circles you see there's a overlap
where you can be doing correct form or
where it's internal or you could be
doing an external form you guys
understand that so like when you're
slipping and stuff
okay um and I would say you guys are
going in and out of internal that's
what's happening okay it's not purely
exteral all right but I still have have
a uh mind thing to do right so meaning
if I operate at this level where I can
keep my mouth open and breathe through
my
mouth
um I'm probably more towards that
external where I want to get eventually
is in the dropping of the mind okay do
you understand just like Z in so then
then you're not going to be so tense you
can
okay he he's doing what he's doing okay
and you're trying to do that meditation
aspect and you know that your tension is
stopping you from sending the Yang to
the ground
okay don't get contagious by there you
go again that happened with Sean cuz you
can feel how relaxed I am then you start
to go relaxed okay you have to stay the
same that's why we have a get in this so
I can work on being relaxed you can feel
how light I am
and what I'm doing is healing my
mind duplicate
my zen state do you understand
[Music]
okay and you notice there's a lot more
stickiness
okay you're getting more in the I than
the overlap of the C you and the pushing
okay try it
[Music]
okay so
uh what What's your mind doing what do
you what do you feel what do you think
where where are you occupied what's
going on there what do you think re look
back and
reflect uh I feeling
like I'm just like where's the end
where's I don't have him uhhuh I I feel
like I don't have seizure okay good and
I would say that too I would say your
mind is on what he's doing and the task
that you're trying to accomplish okay
and I would say you most of you are like
that
okay but if you listen to what I just
said I I said I'm trying to get the mind
to drop and to feel like de that's what
I said so where do you think I'm putting
my
conscious is it in what I'm trying to do
to her and what she's
doing no it's all it's in me okay so
that's what I'm talking about so I I
feel what I'm
doing I don't feel what you're you're
not relevant to me so you change
something and I don't move go ahead then
I felt something different in me you see
that so I go I'm doing my ye my young
descending my mind is descending and I'm
trying to keep that feeling as she's
doing whatever I'm doing doing micro
adjustments to keep that same feeling in
me
they came out on me
[Music]
okay then your feet get really freaking
stuff my hips can move here like usually
you don't want to move your hips but my
hips can
[Music]
move okay you're just not going anywhere
this the structure doesn't Mo anymore
where we want to get
okay when the structure
matters then I got to keep my feet
still okay so it as as we're moving I
can still do all the all the same
[Music]
thing e okay cuz this thing's going to
move because I know if I'm here and I
try to root do you see I'm at the angle
we know she's going to turn towards me
right well now I'm rooted in front of
her you see
that and I don't want to go back to here
she turns towards me and this is
external you I don't want to lose your
Center okay so we have to get to
where everything above the
feet is entirely
in okay then we can start moving our
okay